ماذا لو قلنا هذا الصباح ان 8% من حمض
النووي يتكون من بقايا فيروسات قديمه
بالاكثر من ذلك ماذا لو قلنا ان 40% من
جناتنا لها اصل فيروس سي وكل ذلك يجعل من
مجال بكتيريا الامعاء مفتاحا للشفاء من
الفداء ودواء مايكروبات الامعاء لها عدد
من الوظائف مثل الهضم تعزيز المناعه حمايه
الجسم من الكائنات الدقيقه المسببه
للامراض هذا معروف والمعروض ايضا منذ عقد
من الزمان انا التغيرات الميكروبيه هي عام
الاساسيه وراء العديد من امراض المناعه
الذاتيه مثل السكري من النوع الاول ومرته
لنبسط الموضوع لكم يعمل العلماء اليوم على
توجيه الميكروبات الموجوده في الامعاء
لعلاج الامراض المناعه الذاتيه اه
والامراض المزمنه ماذا يعني ذلك يعني انا
قد نشهد نهايه مرض خطير مثل الزهايمر به
حبوب تحفز نمو البكتيريا المفيده
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]